(whooshing)
- Believe.
- Hello believe nation, today
we're going to talk about
the power of belief.
And as always guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really inspires you,
please leave it down
in the comments below,
put quotes around it as well,
so other people can be inspired.
And when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to sink into yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(inspiring music)
- I want you to look
at something right now.
Think of some major goal you want or
maybe it's one you're already working on
and you have experienced
a lot of set backs,
a lot of defeats.
You've experienced a
lot of disappointment.
Maybe you've already given up.
And maybe you just need a little fire,
a little encouragement to
get back in the game again.
Here's what I want you to look at.
There are winners and there are losers
and there are people
who have not discovered
how to win.
And all they need is some coaching.
All they need is some help and assistance,
just a little support.
All they need is some insight.
Or a different strategy, a
plan of action to make some
adjustments that will open up the key
to a whole new future for them.
That will give them access
to the unlimited power
that they have within themselves.
That's all that they need.
So what I want you to do is think about
something you want for you.
That's real for you.
That's important for you.
That will give your life some
special meaning and power.
And I don't even want
you to say I can do that.
I don't want you to assume that.
See, five years ago when
I started in this area
I would not have been able
to make the mental leap
that I would be up to
where I am right now.
I don't want you to begin
to just psych yourself out.
No, no, I want you to be
able to say something to
yourself that will enable
you to maintain a level
of integrity with yourself.
That when you say this, even
when you face tremendous
set backs, it will be a benchmark
to keep you in the game,
to keep you moving
forward and experimenting
and readjusting your strategy
and your plan of action
continuously looking for ways to win.
So what is that something?
When you got an idea you want to move on.
You might not have the money,
you might not have the education.
You might not have the support
or the resources you need.
What is that something
that can keep us going,
that will enable us to act
on our dream?
What's one of those keys
that will begin to help us
to discover the secrets to our dream?
Here's what I want you to
repeat after me, please,
with power and conviction,
say it's possible.
- [Audience] It's possible.
- That's all I want you to do
when you look at your dream.
Just say to yourself
every day, it's possible.
Just say that every day to
yourself, it's possible.
Because what does that do?
See, it begins to change
your belief system.
See, the way in which we
operate ladies and gentlemen
it's a manifestation of what
we believe what's possible
for us.
Whatever you've done up to this point,
all that it really is is a duplication,
it's a reproduction of what
you believe subconsciously
that you deserve and what's
possible for your life.
Before April 1954,
the common belief, the universal belief
because it had been tried
again and again and again
and people had failed.
The belief was that man
was not physically capable
of breaking the four minute barrier.
That he could not run a mile
in less than four minutes.
That was the belief on the planet.
It had never been done.
But here's what happened
ladies and gentlemen,
Roger Bannister came along.
And he broke the four minute barrier.
Now here's what's significant about that.
Since that time, up to this
day, over 20,000 people
have done it, including high school kids?
What changed?
20,000 people, what changed?
Here's what happened when
they got on the track.
They knew it had been done.
And because they knew it had been done,
there was a new belief about this barrier.
About this goal that was unreachable.
And those 20,000 people
got in the race believing,
knowing in their heart
that someone had done it,
that it's possible, that they could do it.
And I'm saying that if you know
anybody that had some goal,
some dream, something
that they wanted to do,
and they did it then I'm saying
that you know in your heart
that if someone has done
it, then you can do it.
It's possible.
And that if someone can
make that dream become
a reality, that it's possible
that you can make your
dream become reality.
- First day I went to school,
I was in a classroom.
By the time I was, ya know, six years old.
Didn't go to school till
I was six years old,
'cause I was living with my
grandmother at that time.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
- But she had taught me how
to read, read the bible,
bible stories.
So I went into the
classroom knowing Nicodemus,
Shadrach, Meshach and Abednego.
I could spell all of those words.
I thought I was, ya know,
I was preaching to my
kindergarten teacher.
(interviewer mumbles)
So, she was like who is this girl?
So, I was never placed in
an environment where I was
ever made to feel inferior.
I always felt like I'm the
smartest kid in this room.
And because I was never put in a position
where I was made to feel less than,
I didn't grow up feeling
less than, ya know?
- And the rest, as they say, is history.
- And the rest they say is history.
And it's all about what you believe.
You know, I say this
to, when I do something
on my network now called Life Class.
The fundamental key to
success is what you believe
is true for yourself.
Not what you want, not what you desire,
it's what do you believe?
You know, you can say I want
to be the most successful
person in the world, but
if you believe that there's
a glass ceiling and you're
going to have a hard time
kicking through that glass ceiling,
you will be defined by the glass ceiling.
And the great beauty and gift of my life
is that I was never defined
by the box that other
people tried to put me in.
- Stripping that all back
to the start of your career,
a man with a dream, ya
know, training at the gym
day in and day out.
If somebody said to you
you'll be as successful as you
are now, what would you
have said back then?
- I believe ya.
That's what I would have said.
Because I did believe.
I believed in it.
- That's an important part.
- I had very few people who told me that,
I had a small, small,
small group of people
that would tell me something like that.
Other than that, it was
just me telling myself.
So if someone came up
to me and told me that
all the way back then,
I'd say you're damn right.
- One of the things that's
so fascinating to me,
is that Amazon and Jeff
Bezos have pursued what might
be described as a very
asset heavy business model.
They're buying airplanes.
They want to own the entire
supply chain from beginning
to end.
And Alibaba has effectively
an asset like business,
it is very much in terms of
the retail piece of this,
the opposite.
You don't want to own the
warehouses, you don't want to
own the logistics companies.
How do you think about that?
Is Jeff Bezos right or are you right?
And is there going to be
a meeting in the middle?
- I hope both are right.
'Because the world can
never have one model.
If the world has only one correct model,
the world's too boring.
All right, we need to
have all kinds of models.
And the people who do
the model should believe
in the model.
And I believe what I do.
The difference between Amazon and us,
Amazon is more like an empire.
Everything they should control themself,
buy and sell.
And our philosophy is that
we want a bigger ecosystem.
Our philosophy is to
empower others to sell,
empower others to service.
Empower making sure the other
people are more powerful
than us.
Making sure with our tech
knowledge, our innovation,
our partners, our 10 million
small business sellers,
they can compete with Microsoft, IBM.
Our philosophy is that
we think using internet
tech knowledge we can make
every company become Amazon.
- Yeah, I think if you
don't actually believe
what you're doing is really important,
if you don't derive satisfaction
from what you're doing
then you will not be able to
sustain all of the bad things
that happen and the
incredibly long period of time
that the bad things happen over.
And so the only motivation that
I have seen work for people
over a long period of time
is enjoyment in what they're
doing and an intense
belief that it matters.
And ideally, liking the people
that they go to work with
every day.
But the, I think the reasons
that a lot of people,
and by the way, it's totally
cool when people start off
saying well, I want to make
money or I want to be famous.
I think a lot of people
start that way and they don't
like to admit it.
But pretty quickly, or at
least in the first few years,
I think a lot of people
find a deeper mission
for why they do what they do.
And that that drives them
then for the rest of the time
they work.
- What you represent now
for all those kids out there
trying to make it in whatever field it is,
whether it's music or something else,
what words do you have
for them in terms of how
you've lived your life and
you've made it to this point,
'cause you're not supposed
to be here right now.
- No, no.
- What advice do you have for
them in terms of their lives
and their journey?
- Lace up, lace up.
- What does lace up mean, for
say it's the casual person
that might be seeing you for
the first time on this show,
what is lace up?
- I mean it means what
you want it to mean,
but to me, in a day and
age like this it means,
put both feet on the
(bleep) ground, lace up,
get ready to face the world, go out there,
take it on and ya know,
turn a grain of sand into a diamond.
You know what I'm saying?
- I think they love that
answer right there. (laughs)
They're definitely laced up.
- See that's what it's about
man, you know what it's about?
It's about believing in something,
you know what I'm saying?
Like having faith in something man.
Like that's what it is like,
we're not trying to hear some,
we're not trying to hear some
you know president in a suit
who can't even live his own life, ya know,
because he's so worried
about public perception.
We can't relate to that,
ya know what I'm saying?
Like they want to see someone
doing what they're doing,
living how their living, coming from
where they're coming from
and like making something
better of themselves than
just sitting on their ass,
ya know what I'm saying?
Like that's why they're
screaming, like they, because,
they see that in us.
And that's what I'm
coming with on this album.
I'm just going to be the people's champ.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't want to hear some
reverend telling me I have
to believe in an organized religion.
I don't want to hear some
president telling me what he's
going to do and not going to
do, because they never do it.
I don't want to hear some
teacher put a limit on
where my education can take
me, you know what I'm saying?
Like they want to teach me to, ya know,
go and fix lights in the house,
but you don't want to tell me
that I can take my own
career into my own hands
and be an entrepreneur and come
up with something like this.
They didn't teach you you could do this.
- Yeah.
- I'm just not, I'm not scared
man, I'm ready to step up
and be a leader for this generation
and be a voice for this generation
and all these people can
act like they're talking for
these kids, but it's just
an act, like I'm still one
of those kids man.
Like this means the world to me,
and that's what this album is about.
And I just know things
are going to change man.
I feel it, I feel it.
I believe in like, I dunno.
- If you want to be a
fireman go and do it.
If you want to be a ballet dancer then go
and be a ballet dancer.
If you don't believe in yourself,
then no one else will believe in you.
And yeah, it's so
important for me for people
to understand that.
That I want to be an inspiration.
- I was bullied as kind of
nine out of 10 children are
and I want to be a role model
and I think now I'm in the
kind of lime light to go
it's okay, and it's the
special people that are bullied
ya know?
The ones that have something magical
and it's something that you
can turn into a positive
and not let it eat you
away and they'll always
be someone that says you can't do it.
There'll always be someone that
says I don't believe in you.
There'll always be someone
that says I do believe in you.
There's always someone
that says you can do it.
And that's the people
that you have to focus on.
However much people try and put me down,
which they do, when they say you know,
every time I hear your song
I want to burn my ears,
I say who's laughing now?
- My name is Alex Parrish,
protecting our country
had always been my dream.
Quantico was my first audition.
I knew I had to go into this
room and read these lines
in front of all these
people, but I was so nervous
before I went in.
So I went to the bathroom, I
remember, before I went in.
I looked in the mirror and
it's so stupid and cliche'
but I talked to myself and I
said, what's wrong with you?
You've played the most
difficult characters
in the most complicated movies.
Tossed my hair a little bit,
felt great and walked out,
did my bit and got the job.
- What's your message
for viewers out there
about following their dreams?
- I would say if you
truly believe in something
and you really have a
passion for something,
then go for it.
I think there's a lot of
obstacles that you have
to go through and nothing's
ever given to you.
And it takes a lot of
hard work and dedication,
but if you really believe in it,
then you should do it.
- And so you really have
to believe the internet's
going to be mainstream.
A lot of people are going
to get out there and use it.
And that they're going
to be willing to pay
for some content.
- Is that the operating
idea that you have?
- Well, each of these
businesses is an entrepreneurial
business, the over
reaching theme is that yes,
I believe in the internet.
I believe it'll get increasingly popular
and we're doing some neat
new things to take advantage
of that.
- You've got a lot of cash on hand, yes?
- Right.
- All right. (laughs)
And it puts you in an enviable position.
You can experiment with a
lot of entrepreneurial ideas
and see what sticks and what flies.
- Well, we're in business
to make money and,
- But the other thing is providing
such a cash flow for you.
- Well, it all belongs
to the shareholders.
We're not dilatants.
- No, I know.
- We are business people.
And it is true that if you find an idea
that requires three or
four years of improvement
and patience and really sticking with it,
that we're very good at that.
Take Windows, which we bet our company on.
Everybody who doubted that would succeed,
IBM did not support us in that.
It took longer than we expected.
Over four years before
finally graphical interface
got popular and now people
take it for granted.
It's part of every personal computer
and you just expect it to be there.
That was one of the grand
successes of the company.
In the same way, we're
betting on the internet.
That our tools there
will be popular and that
a few of these content
plays that we've decided
to get involved in, that
the scale and the users
will make those into great businesses.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video.
Which clip resonated the
most wit you and why.
Also is there anything
that you want to share
about the power of belief
that will help the other
members of Believe Nation.
Leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jerry Crawford,
Jerry thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
it really really really
means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying it.
Sot thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.